WHAT DID HE HAVE TO SAY?
>> RODMAN HAD USED A DEROGATORY
WORD IN TERMS OF HOW HE REFERRED
TO PRESIDENT OBAMA, AND FORMER
SECRETARY OF STATE HILLARY
CLINTON, BUT HE ALSO HAD A
GLOWING REVIEW FOR THE NORTH
KOREAN LEADER, A MAN WHOSE
REGIME IS KNOWN FOR RUNNING
LABOR CAMPS AND DEVELOPING
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
FORMER NBA STAR DEN ANY RODMAN
ON THE DEFENSE ABOUT HIS SECOND
AND MOST RECENT TRIP TO NORTH
KOREA.
THE MAN HE CALLS A FRIEND, KIM
JONG-UN.
>> HE HAS TO DO HIS JOB, BUT
HE'S A VERY GOOD.
>> Reporter: RODMAN DESCRIBED
HIM AS A MAN WHO WANTS TO
CHANGE.
DURING HIS FIVE-DAY TRIP, HE WAS
ALLOWED TO HOLD THE LEADER'S
BABY DAUGHTER, WHO HE SAYS IS
NAMED JU AE.
>> FOR.
>> Reporter: AND THEN THERE'S
HIS UNCENSORED THOUGHTS ABOUT
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND SECRETARY OF
STATE HILLARY CLINTON CAUGHT ON
TAPE SHORTLY AFTER HE RETURNED
FROM PYONGYANG.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID IF
QUESTIONED IF HE WAS ABLE TO
SECURE THE RELEASE OF KENNETH
BAY.
>> ASK OBAMA ABOUT THAT.
>> Reporter: THEY WANT YOU WERE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
>> ASK THOSE [ BLEEP ] ABOUT IT.
>> Reporter: WHEN YOU WERE
OVERSEAS, YOU REFERRED TO THE
PRESIDENT AND FORMER SECRETARY
OF STATE USING A DEROGATORY
TERM, WHICH IS CAUGHT ON TAPE.
DO YOU STAND BY WHAT YOU SAID
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT AND THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE
CLINTON?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I WOULD SAY THAT'S VERY EASY, I
WOULD SAY IT DIRECT.
OBAMA, WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
COME TALK TO ME.
OBAMA, I DON'T HATE YOUR GUTS.
HILLARY, I LOVE YOU, BILL
CLINTON, I LOVE YOU.
>> Reporter: EARLIER IN THE
CONFERENCE YOU TALKED ABOUT A
DICTATOR AS A VERY GOOD GUY, HOW
DO YOU RECOGNIZE THAT WITH A MAN
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
OPPRESSING MILLIONS OF HIS
PEOPLE.
>> I'VE SAID THIS TO HIM, I SAY,
YOUR GRANDFATHER AND YOUR FATHER
DID SOME BAD THINGS, I SAID, BUT
YOU ARE TRYING TO CHANGE
SOMETHING.
>> Reporter: AS FOR BASKETBALL
DIPLOMACY, RODMAN SAYS HE INKED
A DEAL WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR TO TRAIN THEIR
BASKETBALL PLAYERS FOR THE
OLYMPICS, ALSO SAYING KIM WILL
ALLOW A GAME BETWEEN U.S. AND
NORTH KOREAN PLAYERS TO TAKE
PLACE ON JANUARY 8th AND 10th OF
NEXT YEAR.
HIS EFFORTS AT DIPLOMACY NOT
CONVINCING TO SOME EXPERTS IN
THE REGION.
RODMAN'S BEHAVIOR NOW ON BOTH OF
THESE TRIPS ARE JUST ABSOLUTELY
OUTRAGEOUS.
IT JUST AIDS AND ABETS ONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS REGIMES IN
REAL TIME.
>> Reporter: WHEN ASKED MORE
ABOUT TRYING TO SECURE BAY'S
RELEASE, RODMAN SAYS HE'S NOT
GOING THERE TO RESCUE SOMEBODY.
HE SIMPLY SAID